if you were a land owner a property
owner or anybody who' had even a modicum
of success under the Zars or your family
or your well that's the next thing you
were classified as an oppressor there
was a a great podcast a couple days ago
Jordan Peterson it was two two of my
Allstars Jordan Peterson and Michael
malice uh talking about this oppressed
oppressor narrative and what societies
will do when things start getting out of
whack what happened in Rwanda even
though it was quite a peaceful State
although poor was that
the notion of group identity became
Paramount and then one ethnic group was
set against the other and what happened
in Rwanda is reminiscent of the sorts of
things perhaps faster and even more
brutal possibly than what happened in
the Soviet Union Mill million people
killed in a span of mere months right in
the most brutal possible way was a
consequence of the valorization of group
identity you saw the same thing
happening in Russia right because and
this happened soon after the revolution
is that the the Communists were
attempting to eradicate burgeois
individuality and so people started to
be classified and judged by group guilt
and then almost immediately after the
revolution if you were a land owner a
property owner or anybody who' had even
a modicum of success under the Zars or
your family or your well that's the next
thing you were classified as an
oppressor and as an enemy of the people
but immediately it spread to your
family even if you didn't own anything
if you had people in your ancestry who
ever dared to own anything which meant
everyone who was even Le they
identified success with oppression you
know which is something that we're
trying very hard to do in our culture at
the moment too which is absolutely
catastrophic we're doing the same bloody
things right dividing people into groups
making group identity Paramount
identifying success itself with with
oppression so do you see do you see what
they are doing they are the oppressed we
are the oppressors and they are trying
to upend the system they want to bring
in as many people as they can control
and they can bring in more voters this
is not a grand conspiracy theory or
anything else just remember it was only
until about two weeks ago that the
Democrats in the mainstream media even
acknowledged there was an issue at the
border a whole bunch of us have been
talking about it for a year right and it
was bubbling up mostly on Twitter thanks
Elon Musk for a year I I've shown you a
million videos of Karin Jean Pierre and
Saki and Biden himself and Kamala and
all these people there's no problem at
the border the border secure blah blah
blah but a whole bunch of us we started
ringing the bells right then they start
paying attention now they're
acknowledging there's a problem and we
damn well better do something about it
now it might be too late but if we don't
start doing something about it now at
least to delay the the insanity then
what Jordan is laying out there will
happen here we will have sectarian
violence on our streets we will have
religious violence on our streets we
have no idea the motives of these people
that have come in and especially in
light of all of the world events since
October 7th like there's some
problems